si on est aussi formateur lui de saint
joseph est actuellement les gamins sont
pas des tests pour être recrutés dans ce
sens formateur au des gamins qui ont été
repérés dans coups de stages ou de
compétition qui viennent de différents
clubs de lille certains de saint joseph
on va aujourd'hui c'est ils sont presque
a changé peut-être leur vie sportive
on espère pour eux qu'ils vont réussir à
intégrer ce centre comité de lutte on
fonctionne une grande majorité avec le
monde scolaire
je pense que c'est un vrai projet
d'équiper les résultats ne tiennent pas
compte uniquement de l'entraînement sur
le tapis on a essayé de constituer une
un contexte le plus favorable possible
pour que les gamins puissent s'exprimer
et à exprimer tout son potentiel
la conseil général accompagne les
sportifs de haut niveau déjà listé donc
sa part des primes de résultats lors des
compétitions des billets d'avion
gratuits par an et sur saint-joseph même
la structure de saint joseph et les
accompagner dans ce sens où il ya une
aide à l'hébergement et aux
interventions des encadrants ce qui nous
a permis d'attraper une nutritionniste à
préparateur physique et de consolider
bien ces structures à gauche
sans ses membres je pense que gamin
s'épanouit chez un adolescent c'est
hyper important il passe ses années
collège avec eux le moins d'embûches
possible donc tout ça est formidable à
vivre deviennent plus battu au plus
autonome responsable rapidement c'est
pour ça c'est formidable
quel que soit l'avenir professionnel
sportif qu'ils auront plus tard